un contenedor rectangular sin tapa
necesita tener volumen igual a 10 metros
cúbicos la longitud de la base es dos
veces su ancho el material para la base
cuesta 10 pesos el metro cuadrado y el
material para los lados cuesta 6 pesos
el metro cuadrado hay que encontrar el
costo del contenedor más barato esto
suena muchísimo un problema de
optimización hay unas restricciones unos
costos si queremos minimizar el costo
entonces vamos a hacer un dibujo para
pasar los datos y resolver el problema
déjame poner por acá el contenedor esto
va a ser un lado del contenedor más o
menos algo así es una caja si es una
caja sin tapa más o menos algo de este
estilo
voy a poner por acá el otro lado digamos
que va como por allá que va como por acá
más o menos estoy intentando hacerlo en
perspectiva y como es una caja sin tapa
bueno aquí aquí tiene un lado acá tiene
otro lado pero como es una caja sin tapa
podemos ver el interior y por tanto
podemos ver esta esquinita de acá
esta esquinita de acá que viene más o
menos de por acá y podemos ver este lado
ok entonces ese de ahí es nuestro con
tenedor vamos a leer la información que
nos dan para ver qué podemos meter acá
entonces dice un contenedor rectangular
sin tapa tiene un volumen de 10 metros
cúbicos estos son importantes para
ponerle que el volumen es de 10 metros
cúbicos dice la longitud de la base es
dos veces su ancho eso también son
importantes entonces dejar de ponerle
digamos que que el ancho es este de acá
va vamos a ponerle x y entonces la
longitud es de 2 x y la longitud de 2
veces el ancho entonces vamos a ponerle
ahí x2 x y la altura pues quién sabe
cuánto sea verdad todavía no nos la han
dado entonces vamos a ponerle digamos h
ok entonces ahí tenemos a x2 x h el
material para para la base cuesta 10 y
para los lados cuesta 6 y hay que
encontrar el costo del contenedor más
barato entonces como que suena que
tenemos que calcular el costo verdad dar
una expresión para el costo déjame
ponerle por aquí costo costo de la caja
costo de la caja va y cómo le hacemos
para encontrar el costo de la caja pues
tenemos que separar según los casos
verdad o sea si tenemos lados cuesta
ciertas cosas y tenemos la base cuesta
otra cosa entonces vamos a separar según
el tipo de helados o la base que
tengamos vamos a empezar con con la base
te parece entonces déjame pintar la base
ahí que todo un poco feo vamos a pintar
la base
con este color naranja entonces es esa
de ahí va y tenemos que encontrar cuánto
nos cuesta la base entonces vamos a
empezar con el costo de la base para
calcular ese costo tenemos que encontrar
primero su área verdad el área de la
base el área de la base es x x 2 x el
área de la base es x x 2 x le voy a
poner si x x 2x pero una vez teniendo el
área aquí nos dice cuánto nos cuesta
cada metro cuadrado de la base es decir
hay que multiplicar este x por 2 x por
este 10 que nos quedaría 10 x x x 2 x
esto de aquí es el área de la x donde el
costo de la base lo va a poner mejor
aquí abajo sale bueno nada lo señaló así
la base
base ahora vamos con los otros dos
cuáles son los otros dos costos pues
ahora tenemos que ver qué le pasa este
lado a este lado estos dos lados se
comportan igual y a este lado con este
lado que también se comportan igual
vamos a pintarlos con color rosa
bueno este éste lo voy a pintar con
color rosa este de acá atrás que es
igualito este también lo voy a pintar
con color rosa y entonces qué sucede con
estos con estas dos con estos dos lados
pues mira cada uno de estos tiene el
lado xy altura h va entonces el área de
digamos este lado es x por h le voy a
poner por acá x por h entonces el costo
el costo de este lado es x por h por 6
6 por x por h ahí va uno de los lados
pero este lado es igualito este de acá
tenemos dos de esos entonces hay que
multiplicar por dos va y de modo similar
estos que ahora voy a pintar con morado
pues también son dos y también podemos
calcular los igualitos y entonces estos
morados
ahora tiene el lado 2x y la altura h
entonces habrá que sumar nos quedaría 2
x 2 x x h valen
otra vez el costo de ese material es de
6 pesos por metro cuadrado y son 2
para entonces 2x h es el área 2x h por
62 x h por 6 es el costo de uno de los
lados pero son dos muy bien entonces
estoy acá es el costo de las energías de
los lados lados déjame simplificar un
poquito entonces el costo de la caja es
igual a 2 por 16 20 x x x s x cuadrada
me queda 20 x cuadrada más 12 x h 12 x h
más 2 x 6 12 x 12 24 24 x h muy bien y
estoy aquí es igual a 20 x cuadrada 20 x
cuadrada más 36 36 x h excelente
entonces lo que tenemos que minimizar es
este costo de acá hay que optimizar 20 x
cuadrada más 36 x h sin embargo esto
está en dos variables x y h cómo le
podemos hacer para pasar esto algo que
si se vamos a hacer algo que sólo tengan
una
pues mira no hemos utilizado esta
condición de acá la del volumen y suena
que esa es la clave verdad entonces cómo
podemos escribir el volumen en términos
de las dimensiones pues multiplicando
las x por h por 2x entonces esto qué
volumen sea igual a 10 metros cúbicos es
lo mismo que decir que x por 2x por h es
igual a 10 o bien aquí nos queda x 42 x
cuadrada h o sea que 2x cuadrada h es
igual a 10 y decir aquí queremos
despejar h para ponerlo en términos de x
pues hay que dividir entre 2x cuadradas
de ambos lados h es igual a 10 entre 2x
cuadrada que es lo mismo que 10 entre 12
55 entre x cuadrado muy bien entonces
este x h podemos cambiar este h por este
valor de acá y nos queda ahora así que
el costo en términos de x ya no va a
haber h es igual a 20 x cuadrada más 36
por h que es 55 / x nada más
simplificamos nos queda que 20 x
cuadrada más aquí es 5 x 36 6 por 5 es
35 por 30 de 150 150 y 30 son 180 180
que hay x arriba y x cuadrada abajo nos
queda que quizá la menos uno sale ya lo
puse así para que sea más fácil de
llevarlo muy bien ahora sí ya tenemos
una expresión que podemos derivar vamos
a hacer eso déjame pasar a la izquierda
entonces esta de aquí es cdx y por tanto
se prima de x para derivar este 2 bajan
2 por 20 es 40 nos queda 40 x más o
menos verdad porque ahora esté menos
baja menos por más es menos nos queda 40
x menos 180 180 y el exponente baje en
1x a la menos 2 muy bien entonces
queremos optimizar esta expresión
queremos ver dónde hay puntos críticos
eso quiere decir que queremos ver dónde
o bien está indeterminada o bien es
igual a cero está indeterminada para x
igual a cero verdad si x es igual a cero
aquí estamos dividiendo entre cero
entonces ahí estaría indeterminado pero
si x es igual a cero pues tenemos varios
problemas verdad por ejemplo aquí no
mide nada aquí tampoco mide nada y h
sería igual a infinito entonces suena
que es una caja muy muy muy grande pero
pues hay como que problemas en ese
sentido entonces ese caso como que no no
entra en el sentido práctico de este
problema así que vamos a saltarnos así
ahora lo que tenemos que hacer es ver
dónde está esta derivada de acá se hace
igual a cero entonces ahora lo que
necesitamos es que 40 x menos 180 x a la
menos 2 sea igual a 0 muy bien cómo le
hacemos para resolver esto pues déjame
ver lo mejor una buena idea es pasar de
180 x a la menos 2 para acá y vamos a
hacer eso sumando 180 x a la menos 2 de
ambos lados tenemos que 40 x es igual a
x al menos 2 muy bien ahora
multiplicando por x al cuadrado de ambos
lados tenemos que 40 40 x al cubo es
igual a ciento ochenta 180 verdad x al
cuadrado cancele este de acá y
finalmente dividiendo entre 40 déjame
bajar tantito dividiendo entre 40
obtenemos que x al cubo x al cubo es
igual a 180 entre 40 el cero se va con
el 0 nos queda 18 cuartos o lo que es lo
mismo 9 medios entonces x al cubo es 9
medios y por lo tanto x es igual a raíz
cúbica la raíz cúbica
de 9 medios le voy a poner 4.5 salen
entonces este es el valor de x muy bien
entonces esto de acá es donde se anula
la derivada y es el único punto entonces
con un poco de suerte debería de ser
nuestro mínimo pero no estamos 100%
seguros de que sea un mínimo entonces
tendríamos o bien que graficar y ver que
sí sí parece haber un mínimo o bien
hacer pues la segunda derivada y
utilizar el criterio de la segunda
derivada vamos a hacer eso que es como
lo que tenemos más a la mano vale pero
bueno si vamos a encontrar la segunda
derivada vamos a ponerle
y mi prima de x
ahorita voy a ver cuánto es este
numerito sale pero primero derivamos se
ve prima de x es igual a la derivada de
40 x es 40 la derivada de esto menos dos
bajas menos como menos es más que hace
más dos por ciento ochenta es 360 x a la
menos tres ahorita este vemos que le
sucede esto
bueno aquí podemos verlo ya verdad que
pasa es que aquí le metemos raíz cúbica
de 4.5 aquí se ve prima de x se ve prima
evaluada en raíz cúbica de 4.5 pues nos
va a quedar mayor o igual a 0 verdad
entonces observación observación cbi
prima de raíz cúbica de 4.5 es mayor o
igual que 0 porque bueno aquí está algo
positivo luego es 360 x x a la menos 3
pero esto es positivo entonces esto es
positivo todo es positivo entonces
definitivamente nos queda positivo eso
que nos dice bueno qué sucede si se ve
prima es mayor o igual que 0 esto quiere
bueno esto sucede porque porque la
gráfica es así verdad porque tenemos una
cosa cóncava hacia arriba entonces la
derivada empieza haciendo este muy
negativa como esto es mayor o igual que
0 va creciendo va creciendo se vuelve 0
y se hace cada vez más y más positiva
pero en particular aquí cuando se hace 0
tenemos un mínimo que es un mínimo
porque es cóncava hacia arriba con cava
asia
arriba
arriba muy bien entonces si en efecto
esto de aquí nos indica que x igual la
raíz cúbica de 4.5 es un punto mínimo
pero eso no es lo que nos pregunta en
verdad lo que nos piden es encontrar el
costo
el costo del contenedor más barato ya
casi terminamos ya no más hay que ver
cuánto nos da y para eso vamos a sacar
la calculadora vale entonces agarramos
la calculadora vamos a ver cuánto nos da
entonces lo primero que necesitamos es
saber bueno lo primero es prenderla
vamos a borrar y necesitamos ver cuánto
es la raíz cúbica de 4.57 voy a poner
4.5 elevado a la raíz cúbica es lo mismo
que elevará la un tercio a la un tercio
enter nos queda un 1.65 09 vamos a
ponerle 1.65 entonces esa es una primera
cosa lo voy a escribir por acá x es
igual a 1.65 va el x óptimo es
aproximadamente igual a 1.65 y ya con
eso en mente el costo de la caja el
costo en 1.65 es aproximadamente igual a
otra vez agarramos la calculadora y
tenemos que ver la expresión verdad la
expresión del costo es estar acá y
además metemos 1.65 ahí para ver cuánto
nos da entonces es 20 x 1.65 elevado
elevado al cuadrado muy bien más más
a 180 x 1.65 a la menos 1 pero lo mismo
que dividir entre 1.65 muy bien
verificamos que todo esté bien 20 x 1.65
al cuadrado más 180 entre 1.75 le
picamos enter y aquí está el costo es
163 puntos 54 entonces esto es
aproximadamente igual a 163 punto 54
pesos muy bien esto de aquí es el costo
mínimo que podemos pagar por un
contenedor que satisfaga estas
características de aquí arriba y bueno
ya nada más para analizar un poquito qué
quiere decir pues esto es más o menos
una caja de 160 pesos pero es una caja
más o menos grande verdad si está más o
menos decente mide 1.75 metros como x
320 y la altura bueno latour hay que ver
cuánto sería pero también sería como 2.3
punto y cachito entonces si es una caja
grande más o menos tiene sentido que
cueste esto de acá
y entonces este es un problema más de
optimización nos vemos hasta la próxima